right so shall I continue right so open
questions so there was a one open
question that um go already been raised
very tantalizing that's sylco conjecture
say Oh seems to be out of which yet so
then I'd like to talk about some sort of
pipe dreams so far
the philosophy sort of see of this
approach was we have some simple point
right some base point right which we can
compute things like the matrix of all
ones and things like that so there is a
simple point
right second there is a point that we
really want to get to one and so far we
said that as long as we have ace where I
call a sleeve zero free sleeve we are
fine and two remarks here that that's
the philosophy but the the practice of
it whenever we hear them a sleeve it
always went through the relaxes
so so and therefore it was related to
Lee Jung face transition so things go
badly
if complex zeros end up too close to the
real axis right and we relate complexity
to the phase transition but in principle
we can go up there so the zeros may be
just evil zeros may be just lurking
everywhere on the real axis
but we still can go around them right
just point you know in physics terms
that would mean that we use the complex
temperatures right well go down or heat
the system going into complex
temperatures so and that would imply
that this notion of phase transition is
really very loosely connected to
computation complexity but um so the
question that I'd like to ask is other
any natural unquote examples problems
like this so it sort of comes close but
I don't think what makes it this example
of ldren mehriban of complex Gaussian
matrix with unit variance and vanishing
expectation vanishing very slowly like
one over log log but is there a like a
minute or example where you say that
there's a lot of phase transition going
on in the young sense meaning that the
zeroes approach the real axis or even
sit there a bar we don't care we kind of
can go over or under yeah so so I don't
have any Oh
there promise world we have good data of
the closure of the set of all possible
you know
right - that's another point that I'm
going to mention but right in the
seconds right so so what I'd like to say
that C is a just initial example I'm not
a problem where the Lee Jung is just all
over the place in phase transitions it
boils it solidifies mouths but we don't
care because we go around it so so far
we we didn't have this example so far if
we could interpolate it was always sort
of around right right but that's the
question is what would you do here
Thanks
so if you stay in the original model
then the original Lee Jung says that
there is no phase transition right they
have a champion at any temperature other
than zero right if if you feel but so
it's still very physical right sit so
what I want to see if if you come up
with like the complex temperatures
: thinks or hitting things but going
into a complex plane I thought about it
that would be good thing so but for that
you will need a bound for the roots not
only like Helmand Li but also on the
other side do we have yeah then yeah do
we have an example but that would have
been an example so that brings up the
next topic so that's even more a kind of
dreamy than this one say so so far that
was the idea and here's the some hand
waving so what if we just its of Isis to
not to have zeros just around the
starting point and around the end point
it suffice and one so this evil evil
zeros may surround zero so that we
cannot really through a sufficiently
wide sleeve but what we say we introduce
some dummy variable go high dimension
and jump over this fence of zeros and in
principle that can always be done that
marker doesn't convince me it's a very
simple argument only that you don't know
how to do it effectively
right so you introduce a new variable
that's responsible for more than the
zeros away if you know where they are
right so what do you do so you move the
like the upper half up you move the
lower one down
you do interpolation then you pull them
back in interpolate it can it be done
efficiently in any interesting case so
the reason it's certain maybe not so
outlandish there it sounds that in all
examples of hardness that we have so far
we do have zeros dents around the end
points I think this I can say without
fear of contradiction that we don't
really have this what happens in the
heart problems in that zeros actually
bog us around the point that they want
to that we want to arrive June so
therefore if we had an example like this
it maybe just maybe we don't need
connected sleeve that we can always lift
it up well in theory yes so that's
exactly as I said so move up the ones up
lower ones down interpolate close them
back so that you interpolate the same
thing again so there's no idea right but
it's a bit suspicious that in all exam
hardness examples we do have zeros kind
of dense around the endpoint
so finally I'd like to go back to the
question that Alistair brought up
yesterday so relation between relations
between correlation decay interpolation
Markov chains so the relation between
interpolation and relation decay
physicists looked at right certainly so
sometimes the young phase transition
will end in non uniqueness of the Gibbs
matter sometimes they're not but so that
sort of certainly people looked at
relation with the mark of change not so
not so much and as I walked here
yesterday on the hotel had an idea that
I'd like to share with you but since
this idea is one day old and we know
that one day all that years rarely see
one week unit anniversary right let
alone one months of one a year so it may
be still I like to talk about it right
because it's been the second day I still
find it okay so what are we after say
suppose that we have this we have this
family from a natural family of subsets
that we started with right and we want
we define the partition function that's
the sum over all sets in the family and
then the product over elements of the
set of the variables is a by so suppose
that we know the the easy point the
reference point is one the point of all
one's just like we had for the permanent
for the
Groff Homer schism so suppose we want to
prove that this function
is not 0 provided these Z's in the poly
disc so close enough to one and we want
to prove it using Markov chains so that
will be our connection so suppose
so what I was saying so we say that
suppose that the reason Markov chain on
this family which makes local moves so
if as goes to s prime then they don't
really differ that much just replaced
100 one element and the matrix of the
steady state is uniform right and the
matrix is symmetric and we have some
control over the spectral gap so
spectral gap right so I want to prove
that in this situation there are no
zeros in the poly disk how would I prove
it I would say something like this I
would say that
suppose the partition function indeed
turns into zero in this politics what
does that mean that means that if I
consider the vector for once
parameterize by subsets in the family
then it will be octagonal
well the scalar product will be 0 with
this vector of monomials that's exactly
what it says right so that the partition
function is 0 so because this scalar
product is the partition function right
so what does that mean that means that
the vector consist enough consisting of
these monomials
isn't the eigenspace all the smaller
smaller eigenvalues well that's probably
what I'm saying is you know what I mean
so it's orthogonal to thee to the
largest eigenvalues eigenvectors say
therefore the matrix a the matrix if
code a the matrix a is a contraction so
a is a contraction with factor Makeda on
this vector but the point is that if the
moves are local it cannot be a
contraction right because what it does
so if i multiply it by this vector
monomials
what it does it replaces it with a
vector some convex combination monomials
utilize pretty much the same variable
maybe one or two different right and if
so if you have that condition that is
close to 1 then you guarantee that it
doesn't contract much right because you
just replace one or two variables that
are close to one but neither there's
close to one you don't replace all them
right or so and that shows that it
really can mean the contradiction
purportedly shows that there are no
zeros in apologies it would be nice to
have examples if it's not a complete
nonsense I mean it seems to hold water
after one day no examples and that's
pretty much I'm out of time right now
I'd like to be so so that's the end of
it
[Applause]